[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
We've got a cool experiment coming
to us from a YouTube comment
from someone using the
name Rick Harrison asking,
"What would happen if we pour
liquid nitrogen onto lava?"
I have no idea if this is the actual
Rick Harrison from Pawn Stars,
but we're going to try it
because it's cool experiment,
not because of who asked.
[Music]
We've got our arc furnace all set up.
We've got some pieces of lava rock,
and we've got a dewer
full of liquid nitrogen.
I've got a safety mask,
thick old gloves,
and everything is set up
to try and make some lava.
The idea here is pretty simple.
We're gonna melt down some
lava rock in our arc furnace,
and then we're going to try
pouring it into a bowl of liquid nitrogen.
After that, we'll melt
down a little bit more,
and see what happens if we pour
the liquid nitrogen onto the lava.
Grant has had some
other videos showing
how he went about
making this arc furnace,
but the basic idea
is that when it's turned on,
when you get these
two leads together,
they begin to arc,
and you can then control where it
blasts thousands of degrees of heat,
and it's enough to melt down most
kinds of metal and most types of rock.
We've had one experiment before where
we did melt some of this lava rock down,
and were able to pour it
out into some sand,
and that's basically
what we want to do again,
except this time,
instead of pouring it in the sand,
we want to pour it
into liquid nitrogen.
[Music]
All right,
let's melt some lava rock.
[Music]
We kind of go through
those little glass dishes.
They're cheap.
That was cool.
All right, so that was...
I don't know.
Looks like about
half a teaspoon of lava
being poured down
into some liquid nitrogen,
and it definitely made
the liquid nitrogen
start boiling like most things do.
Then of course,
it hit the glass,
and there is a huge heat difference
between the hundreds of
degrees below zero nitrogen,
and the probably thousands of
degrees above zero liquid lava,
and the glass couldn't
take quite that much stress.
All sorts of fun noises
from our crucible
as the lava inside
cools back down,
and contracts a little bit.
We tried pouring a little bit of
our lava into some liquid nitrogen,
and it cooled it down rapidly,
broke the container it was in,
but now we're going
to try the opposite,
and try pouring some
liquid nitrogen into our lava.
[Music]
Lava and liquid nitrogen.
Obviously, we only have the ability to
create very small amounts of lava
with the tools we have here,
but I'd be pretty interested
to see this experiment scaled up
to the point where
we could really pour
a good amount of
lava into something.
You're gonna have to
research the best way to do that.
Pouring our lava into the liquid nitrogen,
it cooled down rapidly forming
these little black glass beads,
and pouring the liquid nitrogen
onto our lava, it did cool down,
but not as fast as I thought it would.
I went through about a cup of
liquid nitrogen pouring it on,
and the lava inside was solidified,
but it was still glowing orange.
So it had a ton of heat in it.
Keeping in mind that so far,
we only had the ability to
make very small amounts of lava,
are there any other things
you'd like to see us do with it?
We can get maybe a teaspoon
of lava to pour out of this thing.
One of the main restrictions is
that as we use the arc furnace,
it heats up the carbon rods,
and then the heat even begins
to go into the vice grips
that the carbon rods are attached to.
So after not too long,
it gets too hot,
even through my thick
leather furnace gloves.
That limits how long
we can keep it going,
and how much lava we can make.
But with that amount of lava,
is there anything cool you'd
like to see us pour it on to?
Thank you YouTube user
Rick Harrison for your suggestion.
Check your YouTube inbox,
we're sending you 25 bucks.
Remember, if you suggest something
that we use to make a video,
we'll send you $25.
Guys, we've got more for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will
show you what YouTube thinks
you need to be watching next.
This bomb here in the middle
will subscribe to the channel,
so you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.